how did brands gain such control in our
lives and how will brands function in a
rapidly changing world this three-part
series entitled the 22nd century brand
is brought to you by design Singapore
the national agency for design enabling
Singapore to use design for economic
growth and to improve lives
in these discussions we will be looking
at the origin of brands how brands
function in our contemporary cultural
landscape and the future of brands where
it's all headed my name is hunter Tara
I'm the founder and CEO of an
international brand design consultancy
called syndicate X over the past 25
years I've had the opportunity to work
with some of the world's leading
organizations across culture commerce
and technology and I've helped them
develop clear brand stories and I've
helped them articulate their value
proposition I've worked with
multinational corporations such as
Netflix Nike GE Unilever Lululemon OD
and Asics to some of the world's leading
museums and cultural institutions
including the Victoria and Albert Museum
and the John F Kennedy Center for the
Performing Arts through these
collaborative partnerships I've had the
opportunity to see how brands really
work and to witness the power they have
in our collective consciousness this
series is intended to share some of the
insights and secrets I've been able to
gather over the course of my career our
first discussion is on the origin of
brands and in particular we will explore
the peculiar set of dynamics that have
made brands such a ubiquitous part of
contemporary life and how our
affiliation with brands has displaced
our fundamental connections to nature
and to one another
first we're going to start with a little
test for those of you watching at home
I'm wondering how many of you can name
these six types of trees
no don't feel bad I've done this test
over the years many times with my
students and at conferences and in that
time only one guy got all six and he was
a landscape architect now let's try
another test can you name these six
brands I thought so but this test is
meant to illustrate is how our
understanding of and our connection to
brands has fundamentally displaced
humankind's basic relationship to our
natural surroundings if you think about
it five hundred years ago if you didn't
know which trees these were you could be
poisoned or worse and today we can't
even identify what surrounds us what we
do know is in our contemporary age
brands are everywhere
let's also start with some basic
terminology
[Music]
we hear a lot about brands and branding
in business and culture and in fact
almost everything today is considered a
brand consumer products content
influencers even cities such as
Singapore considered brands that have
standards and guidelines that govern
their image and communications but let's
keep it simple when I talk about brand
what I'm really talking about is the
image and reputation of a company or
organization and when I talk about
branding that is how an organization or
company uses design and language to
maintain that image and reputation
simple right well yes and no and that's
what we're going to explore more deeply
in this series
[Music]
how did brands gain such control in our
lives and how old brands function in a
rapidly changing world with
technological innovation a world made
even more uncertain by the Cova 19
pandemic before I went into a career in
design I actually trained to be a
historian and I still think about things
in historical terms how to understand
our current and future state through the
lens of the past and what the lessons of
the past can teach us about where we're
going this is a diagram I drew a few
years ago for a project in China I think
it's still relevant and explaining the
evolution of brands over the past 200
years we'll get into the 21st and 22nd
century in later episodes but today
we're gonna go back in time to
understand where we came from
historically brands have been thought of
as static entities trademarks that
represent a product or service and
denote a certain quality and consistency
when looking through the historical lens
of brand we can begin to see unified
systems as far back as the Roman Empire
this image is an excerpt from my
graduate thesis done as part of the
Harvard project on the city under the
direction of the Dutch architect REM
koolhaas although historians have
traditionally presented Rome as the
basis of Western civilization through
legal codes cultural expression
infrastructure and trade in fact Rome
might be thought of as the first truly
global brand as Rome expanded across
most of Europe and into the Middle East
Africa and parts of Asia they used a
consistent visual language in their
buildings uniforms and currency even in
the layout of their cities
I like to say that Rome was the original
Starbucks well every Starbucks store has
slight variations in its design and
layout when you're in a Starbucks
anywhere in the world it's immediately
recognizable as a brand by the
Renaissance in Europe and with the
resurgence of global commerce we begin
to see the consistent usage of brand
imagery for example the artois brewery
in Leuven Belgium has been using the
same logo since 1366 it only added the
now iconic star element in the 1920s
with the advent of the Industrial Age
and the rising notion of intellectual
property brands worried about Impostors
what today we call knock-offs
as every student of branding knows a
sale was the first registered trademark
in the UK in 1877
it's my belief that an alternative
history of the 20th century can be told
through the impact of the brands that
defined its direction from the iconic
script logo of the Ford Motor Company
which represented mass industrialization
in corporate efficiency the
professionalization of management and
corporate efficiency brought to a global
scale it opened up attainable personal
mobility to millions for the first time
but also it brought with it the negative
effects of our reliance on fossil fuel
and our impact on the natural
environment to the peace symbol shown
here the now infamous 1968 Democratic
National Convention in Chicago which
came to symbolize the global
counterculture movement of the 1960s and
is still used to represent a series of
values and principles related to
environmentalism social justice equal
rights and non-violence to Steve Jobs
Apple logo a logo that is synonymous
with technological innovation and
increasingly represents the power of
great design to make an impact and
improve our lives
[Music]
as my colleague Bruce malwan said
without design Apple is a reasonably
good technology company and with design
is the most valuable corporation in the
history of the planet so what do all of
these logos have in common
they've become representative for the
large-scale social economic cultural
technological changes that have
characterized the century during what I
would call the high period of brand
design the role the designer itself as
an inspired author or a tour of singular
iconic memorable imagery for brand was
established in the cultural imagination
here we see Paul Rand in his studio
coincidentally the designer of Steve
Jobs next load owns the company he
developed during his period of exile
from Apple in the 1990s with some of his
iconic design work pinned up in the
background on the walls of the studio
it's the perfect example an image of the
20th century designer and one that still
exists in the cultural imagination today
[Music]
in 1982 everything changed through a
series of cultural events and business
innovations design has now become
digital and it's now possible for brands
to express themselves in new and
innovative ways and the tools and
techniques of brand expression have now
become accessible to common people in
1982 Adobe was founded Adobe is the
company that is most closely associated
with creating the tools of creative
expression and 1982 Blade Runner was
released changing the way we think about
media and advertisement especially in
cities and public spaces
what's amazing looking at these images
today Blade Runner predicted the
contemporary bourbon condition in global
cities in the United States
MTV reached 1 million households for the
first time in 1982 as a child of the
1980s I can attest to the lasting impact
it made on visual culture it changed
everything that had come before motion
graphics set design costumes hair and
makeup
[Music]
television advertising media would never
be the same and it changed how we think
about brands and of course the computer
was named Time magazine's machine of the
year up to that point Man of the Year
digital technology was now part of
everyday life an increasingly linked to
how we think about the expression of
brands by 1984 when Apple released the
first Macintosh computer and the
now-infamous
corresponding 1984 Super Bowl ad that
year design had become democratized for
the first time putting the tools and
techniques of brand design in the hands
of common people
[Music]
[Music]